[Musique]
la vraie raison de la séparation de brad
pitt et angelina a été dévoilé elle va
vous étonner c'est vraiment étendre
ce chaton aux yeux très gros va vous
émouvoir aux larmes il est trop mignon
l'histoire de cet enfant abandonné qui a
réussi dans la vie va vous redonner foi
en l'humanité
ça va vraiment mieux que la vie est
belle
le récit poignant de ce tour du monde va
vous donner envie de quitter votre job
je démissionne
regardez ce que cette femme fait pour
son bébé prématuré les bras m'en tombent
pas vous hein pas si
[Musique]
cet acrobate de rue est si doué qu'il va
vous faire chier liquide parlure est
vraiment doué ce discours d'un chômeur
un élu va vous choquer et vous donner
envie de renverser la vème république
[Musique]